well
and once he suspended the brotherhood layer
sigma after a student
they promoted died in a
boxing fight how do you greet cristian
casseres he tells me in valencia he collapsed in
a benefit fight on
November 19 and died 4 days later  of
this event clark county says it did not
give permission or any license to
test this fight the university
is also investigating this case we
continue to provide coverage of a
video showing a person of
interest in connection to the death of a
waitress in belize  Detectives
say the man was near
the scene of the incident when the body was
found earlier this week. At
the beginning, the coroner's office indicated
that his death was related to a
health condition. Now, authorities have
revealed data and are examining new
information.  of what happened if they
recognize him, he is asked to call the
police and more than 1200 employees of
colleges and universities.  ades could lose
their jobs if they are not fully
vaccinated the university educational system
indicated that
december 31 would be the deadline to be
vaccinated about 300 csn employees
and more than 600 navy employees have not obtained
the cob vaccine and 19 and le  we take a
look at the temperatures as we can
see we will have some clouds passing
through the sky of the valley while
we stay in 70 degrees but
we will be back it is still a little colder
for the rest of the week I am cristian
casseres with his brief information on
iris espanyol  good morning
[music]